j'ai pu avoir accès au rapport médico
légal de la sphère donc en fait ce que
révèle ce rapport c'est qu'effectivement
il ya eu quelques contusions au niveau y
aurait eu j'utilise quand même le
conditionner quelques contusions au
niveau du coccyx qui ont valu à la
victime présumée
deux jours d'interruption de travail
indique été harry pour l'instant il nie
toujours d'avoir agressé sexuellement
cette cette jeune femme la victime à
l'heure d'aujourd'hui je vous le cache
pas elle est selon mes infos extrêmement
mal en fait est là elle a des crises
d'angoissé et des grosse panique parce
qu en cause de l'ampleur que prend le
faire à cause de l'ampleur que prend la
faire enfin sa plus grande peur c'est
que son nom soit révélé dans la presse
donc vous donc voila et quant à harry
lui pour l'instant tout à l'heure je
vous disais il y avait une réunion de
crise il ya une dizaine de jours pour
savoir un peu comment il allait aborder
la chose pour l'instant il s'est mis au
vert chez un ami dans une maison enfin
dans la maison d'un ami en région
parisienne et et voilà il se fait un peu
petit en attendant peut-être et ça ça
s'accompagne le soutien alors ouais ça
que mes fans le soutien elle pourrait
même
ouais elle est amoureuse qu'elle soit
sinon elle est amoureuse et donc malgré
ce qui est sûr en tout cas dans
l'histoire on sait pas si agression
sexuelle ou pas mais c'est parole contre
parole mais ce qui est ce qui est sûr
c'est que voilà il a trompé sa compagne
et pourtant elle est toujours là elle
pourrait même apporté son témoignage aux
dossiers en disant que bahari n'a jamais
été violent avec elle après ski ce qui
peut certainement se produire c'est
qu'il risque d'avoir une nouvelle
confrontation entre la victime présumée
et ary abittan janvier et je pense que
c'est à ce moment là où tout va un peu
se décider quelle va être la réaction d'
harry quelle va être la réaction la
plaignante la plaignante va être se
retirer va s'excuser enfin voilà il ya
plein d'hypothèses qui sont possibles et
je pense que c'est à ce moment là que la
carrière de dari pourra reprendre ou pas
j'ai vous donnez des enfants pour le
moment du côté de la victime présumée
c'est silence absolu aucune information
ne filtre aucune volonté de médiatiser
de parler alors ça peut changer dans ces
affaires là des avocats
l'avocat pour le moment dit je ne veux
absolument pas ni parler moi même ni que
ma cliente apparaissent nick rien ne
soit révélée alors c'est un juge
d'instruction également qui incite au
silence donc est-ce que ou arrêt
habitants où la victime présumée va
rompre le silence pour communiquer pour
le moment contrairement à bien d'autres
affaires du genre c'est silence absolu
alors au début nous on essayé de
négocier avec elle une interview
exclusive avec l'anonymat et puis et
puis là vraiment elle répond plus du
tout aux appels elle veut vraiment
essayé d'un peut se faire petit blier de
gérer le stress que ça lui aurait causé
et au niveau 2 des informations sur la
sortie de ses prochains films ce
spectacle pour ckoi laissant alors là
pour l'instant tout ce qui est son
spectacle pour de vrai tous cas être
cités prévue au mois de novembre a été
annulé il y avait une date qui était
prévu au pavillon baltard échoué pour y
jouer son spectacle en faites pas il
pourrait jouer après je pense que voilà
il a peut-être peur que les gens me
voient ils pourraient le faire en fait
il pourrait le faire qu'il ya des dates
qui ont été reportés en février c'est
pour ça que si l'une consiste en une
continuation sienne une nouvelle un
nouvel arbitrage au mois de janvier lors
d'une nouvelle confrontation les choses
pourraient un peu changé donc voilà pour
l'instant les soit ça a été reporté soit
ça a été annulé voilà pour son spectacle
août